welcome to this special edition of
hannity
justice in america i'm judge jeanine
pirro in for sean
and tonight we start with the economy
under the biden administration taxes
spending and the deficit
are all at record levels as a result
your money
and your paychecks are now worth less
than ever
inflation just climbed a whopping five
percent in may
meat fruits vegetables lumber everything
you
buy is now more expensive gas is up 56
percent over last year
this is a crisis and tonight americans
are understandably
upset in a brand new axios focus group
only three out of 13 voters said they
felt the u.s economy
is booming while most feared an
impending collapse
the group was also worried about
unemployment and
blamed the government for so many people
out of work
quote nearly all of the voters believe
that people are not looking for jobs
because they make more from claiming
unemployment benefits
unfortunately the economy is just one of
the many crises unfolding under biden
as we speak two iranian warships are
sailing
across the atlantic they are likely
headed to venezuela
to reportedly deliver seven fast attack
ships
that could be used to disrupt key
american supply routes around the panama
canal
it's unclear if the biden administration
has any plans to stop this
or any potential arms deal there are
also concerns that biden's upcoming
meeting
with vladimir putin will be a disaster
today the russian president sat down
with nbc
and trashed biden ahead of their meeting
watch you once described president trump
as a bright person
talented how would you describe
president biden
no well even now i believe that former
u.s president mr trump
is an extraordinary individual talented
individual
otherwise he would not have become u.s
president he's a colorful individual
you may like him or not and but he
didn't come from the u.s establishment
he had not been part of big-time
politics before and some like it
some don't like it but that is a fact
president biden of course is radically
different from trump because president
biden is a career man
he spent virtually his entire adulthood
in politics
just think of the number of years he
spent in the senate a different kind of
person
and it was my great hope that yes there
are some advantages some disadvantages
but there will not be any impulse-based
movements on behalf of the sitting u.s
president
clearly this upcoming meeting will be
highly contentious
and you have to wonder if joe biden is
up to the task
but the mainstream media doesn't care
time magazine just published an absurd
cover where they tried to make biden
look as cool and powerful as possible
no easy feat i might add hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else